Bitcoin just hit
$35,000 this is a pretty big deal
because Bitcoin hasn't been at this
price range since May 2022 and just in
this week alone Bitcoin is up
23% but where is the price of Bitcoin
going and is it ever going to go to zero
well the best way to find out is to take
a look at history the peak price of
Bitcoin in 2015 was
$465 in 2016
$977 2017 during the bull market just
under
$20,000 20 18 18K 2019 just under 13k
2020 $228,800
$67,800
2022 just under $50,000 so if you zoom
out you can see that Bitcoin is
constantly moving on an upward
trajectory up and to the right based on
this history and the fact that the
Bitcoin harving is less than 6 months
away I think you'd be pretty stupid to
not be bullish on bitcoin right now